bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau 78
société nous nous intéressons à ce qui
fait débat actuellement et en ce moment
on parle évidemment beaucoup de
l'écotaxe alors les écologistes sont
pour les transporteurs routiers les
agriculteurs sont contre la grogne est
forte en Bretagne elle gagne d'R vre
département comment cela se vit-il dans
les Yvelines alors pour en parler avec
nous François Lecoq bonsoir vous êtes
agriculteur séréalier précisément à
Oudan et secrétaire général de la
fédération départementale de la
FNSEA fédération agricole majoritaire
Olivier Parj bonsoir et vous êtes
csecrétaire départemental d'Europe
Écologie les vers alors avant de
commencer cet entretien et puis c'est
surtout cette discussion on va débuter
avec un chiffre le chiffre bah c'est le
chiffre 3 tout simplement parce que
c'est le nombre de portique écotax
implanté dans le département alors selon
une carte fournie par ecomove qui est la
société dont on entend beaucoup parler
en ce moment il y en a effectivement
trois dans les ivelines on va les
découvrir il y a effectivement un point
écotax sur l'autoroute à 12 au niveau du
triangle de r encour en allant vers 50
ans en ivelin comme ça on est vraiment
précis sur la nationale 10 à hauteur de
trappe et sur la 13 vers et queeville
alors en tout en France ça représente
quand même 15000 kilm de route nationale
et départemental qui sont concernés par
la mise en place de cette écotaxe pour
environ 100 80 porti qui ont été mis en
place alors le 29 octobre dernier le
gouvernement a suspendu cette
écotaxe alors à votre avis est-ce une
bonne idée de l'avoir suspendue faut-il
la rétablir faut-il carrément la
supprimer François leco déjà rétablir
une vérité il vous manque un ah c'estove
he c'est précis sur la nationale 12 au
niveau de Houdan nous avons aussi un
porticque donc qui est très qui regarder
de près c'est pour ça que je vous je
sais bien où vous dites regarder de près
par l'agriculture
et tous les gens contre le contre contre
le projet vous allez pas l'enflammer
quand même vous allez pas
suivre breton d'accord desbretons alors
suppression rétablissement
suspension le ministre le Premier
ministre a annoncé une suspension nous
nous voulons une suppression de
l'échotaxe pour repréciser les choses il
est évident que dès le départ cette
échotaxe avait été mise en place pour
éviter que des produits qui viennent de
loin enfin soi taxés par le nombre de
kilomètres il faisait sur les routes
pour arriver jusqu'au consommateur et en
fait on s'aperçoit nous au niveau local
sur les evvelines que c'est l'inverse
qui se produit nos petits producteurs
qui font du maréchage de l'œuf de
l'aviculture des fruits et légumes vont
passer sous ces portiques sur les
départementales parce qu'il faut
rappeler que ces portiques ne concent
pas ne sont pas installés sur des
autoroutes payantes sont peut-être plus
emprunté par les agriculteurs venant
d'Espagne voilà dans les pour les
grandes distances ces gens-l ne
passeront pas sous les portique ou juste
en arrivant sur R gistre donc nous il
est évident que nos petits producteurs
sont impactés très très
fortement au local Olivier Parj alors
d'abord suspension suppression
rétablissement vous dites quoi alors
déjà bon sur le fait que il y ait une
suspension je pense qu'on était dans une
un climat qui faisait que de toute façon
mal enem mancher mal expliqué au bout
d'un moment c'était peut-être plus
raisonnable de suspendre de suspendre la
taque et son la taxe et son application
par contre ce qui est là où on va être
on va nécessairement avoir une
divergence c'est c'est quelque chose qui
pour nous allait dans le bon sens elle
elle est pas nécessairement bien née et
elle son application peut être vue et
j'espère que gouver est-ce que vous
comprenez ce que dit François leco en
disant finalement ça pénalise les
agriculteurs locaux de proximité qui
vont faire des allers-retours fréquents
sur des route départementale nation déjà
ça ça ne pénalise que les camions qui
font plus de 3 tones5 donc c'est quand
même déjà un
une certaine taille il y a d'autres pays
comme l'Allemagne où c'est seulement les
camions de 12 tonnes par exemple qui
sont taxés donc ça pourrait par exemple
être un aménagement au moins temporaire
donc ça c'est des choses sur lesquelles
effectivement on peut tout à fait
discuter après les portail je signale
juste que les portails servent au
contrôle mais absolument pas à la
perception des écotaxes donc on pourrait
même faire marcher cet taxe que nous on
préfère appeler contribution poids lourd
que écotax après le green washing il y a
peut-être le green bashing donc c'est
plutôt une contribution poids lourd qui
qui qui est là pour réétablir le le prix
du transport donc cette contribution
poids lourd peut être complètement perçu
sur les 15000 km de route française sans
ses portique donc on peut s'attaquer à
ces portiques mais c'est c'est juste du
contrôle euh donc le gouvernement do en
fait on s'attaque au porti ça sert à
rien mais ça coûte cher he de de ça
coûte cher pardon pour le contribuable
français quand les portiques sont
détruit ah B bien sûr bien sûr mais par
contre l'installation complète la la
l'installation complète ecove c'est
aussi des GPS dans tous les camions
c'est aussi des satellites c'est aussi
tout un centre donc il y a aussi tous
ces tous ces frais là d'ailleurs Françis
est-ce que vous aviez équipé vous vos
camions de de GPS déjà et de petits
boîtiers sympathique moi à mon niveau
donc je suis céréalier je n'ai pas de
camion ce sont des camions qui viennent
chez nous chercher nos denrées agricoles
et les emmener sur les ports de rouan et
et divers ports euh où où où la taxe est
est vraiment euh délicate imaginez des
producteurs de salade qui vont du champ
avec des petits camions même si Monsieur
dit 3 ton5 c'est c'est c'est c'est gros
euh c'est c'est c'est tout petit hein ça
va vite hein un producteur de fruits et
légumes aujourd'hui fait des fois deux
tours de de de salade euh dans des
camions de de cette taille donc du champ
à revenir à son siège social pour
traiter la salade la laver la
conditionner retirer les feuilles euh il
va déjà avant d' qu'elle aille sur un
lieu de commercialisation elle va déjà
être passée sous un voire deux portiques
euh ça ça paraît déjà assez fort sachant
que au final quand il va remmener son
produit chez son client final il ne
pourra vu que c'est là où la différence
est importante c'est que le producteur
qui a ses propres son propre camion et
qui livre euh un une centrale de grande
surface ne pourra pas forcément
répercuter la hausse qu'il va avoir de
de transport supplémentaire ce qui n'est
pas le cas sera supporté par lui elle
sera obligatoirement supporté par lui
parce que la grande distribution il est
pas évident qu'elle joue le jeu on lui
dira mais monsieur moi de la salade ou
des œufs je peux en trouver hors de
France sans le coût du transport et je
vais aller sera payable par le
consommateur mais tout sera payable par
le consommateur il est évident que quand
on se fera livrer même un camion de fu
domestique ça sera inclus dans le dans
le le prix du litre de file mais c'est
le consommateur et c'est là où il faut
être vraiment très très clair c'est le
consommateur final qui va encore et qui
ne peut plus aujourd'hui payer cette
chge Olivier par pourquoi elle est
fondamentale cette écotaxe pour Europe
écologie des vers pour les écologistes
alors elle est pas fondamentale pour les
écologistes seulement parce écoutez Fran
le on a l'impression qu'elle a que des
inconvénients en fait cette oui mais
enfin faut faut déjà rappeler le
pourquoi on veut mettre en place une
fiscalité écologique donc c'est pas une
fiscalité qui se veut punitive c'est pas
pour récolter de l'argent supplémentaire
mais c'est pour donner des signes
incitatifs par exemple quand on dit on
veut réduire la TVA sur la rénovation
des logements c'est pour favoriser la la
la rénovation des logement ou alors
c'est une TVA qui peut être euh qui va
avoir un avis qui va avoir un effet qui
va avoir un effet pour expliquer qu'à
long terme le fait d'avoir des milliers
de camions sur toutes les routes de
France et du monde qui vont faire qu'il
y aura plus de gaz à effet de serre je
vous rappelle quand même que la France
s'est engagée à réduire de 20 %
et l'Europe d'ailleurs sétait engagé à
réduire de 20 % ses gaz à effet de serre
en 2020 il va bien falloir y aller donc
la façon que peut avoir la fiscalité
d'influer là-dessus c'est de donner une
orientation en expliquant ce type de
transport va coûter plus cher donc s'il
coûte plus cher à terme donc c'est pas
instantané mais à terme c'est pour
réorienter
autrement le le transport on prend
l'Allemagne par exemple qui a mis en
place depuis des années 2005 je crois
une écotaxe donc cette taxe là a
rapporté 4 milliards l'année dernière
4,3 milliards et a permis de faire deux
choses a permis de rénover le le réseau
routier allemand parce que des camions
qui roulent sur les routes que ça soit
national ou départemental les Abî plus
il y a pas besoin d'être très savant
pour pour l'imaginer si aujourd'hui les
collectivités local n'ont pas les moyens
de de rénover ces installations là elles
n'y arriveront pas et donc il est un peu
logique que les camions puissent y
contribuer sinon de toute façon ce sera
pas le consommateur mais ça sera le
contribuable français qui payera donc au
bout d'un moment sur cette taxe vous
êtes pour on va l'établir mais peut-être
voir les règles notamment sur le tonnage
des camions vous par exemple ou sur son
application ou peut-être effectivement
il y a il y a un certain nombre de de
produits le lait je crois qui était qui
était exempté de cette taxe là donc il y
a peut-être des aménagements qui peuvent
permettre de la rendre plus supportable
mais elle permet comme toute la
fiscalité écologique de donner
l'orientation pour qu'à terme ça puisse
se réorienter et juste je finis donc sur
l'Allemagne que j'avais pris comme
exemple il y a la moitié qui va à la
rénovation du réseau routier allemand et
le reste qui va au développement du
ferroutage ou de la du transport fluvial
et donc c'est aussi grâce à cette
réorientation de de de l'argent que on
va pouvoir développer des moyens
alternatifs qui feront que on émettra
moins de gaz à effet de serre et et le
rapport du GC là qui a paru il y a 15
jours 3 semaines montre quand même une
situation alarmante qui se dégrade
effectivement qui se dégrade et il faut
bien que quelque part la France l'Europe
tiennent ses engagements de Mo- 20 % de
de gaz à effet de ser en 2020 on va
continuer cet entretien ce débat dans
quelques instants on est allé à la
rencontre des cantinois pour leur
demander sil cétit pour ou contre
l'cotax et on écoute leur réponse bonne
question je travaille dans le domaine du
bâtiment donc je suis un peu concerné et
ouais c'est pas donné c'est cher au jour
d'aujourd'hui on paye déjà assez de
taxes comme ça et je pense qu'une taxe
supplémentaire c'est c'est du grand
n'importe quoi je suis pour parce que on
a besoin de taxer quand même certaines
choses comme économie économie d'énergie
et tout ça
contre euh déjà trop sur taxé au lieu de
taxer nos agriculteurs français vaut
mieux taxer les agriculteurs étrangers
contre en tant que Breton je suis contre
le soutiens moralement mais globalement
j'étais pour si çaait av été mieux fait
quoi il fallait que ça soit mis en place
tout de suite s'il avait mis en place
dès que ça avait été voté ça serait
passé tranquillement mais là maintenant
ça passera plus maintenant c'est ça
risque d'être compliqué ça risque d'être
compliqué en tout cas c'est sûr en ce
moment c'est assurément compliqué euh je
voudrais justement parce que monsieur
était breton je voudrais qu'on le
revienne sur les événements breton de
ces derniers jours d'abord sur cette
phrase qui est signée de de Bruno Le
Maire qui est ancien ministre UMP de
l'agriculture c'était ce lundi chez nos
confrères de France Info il a dit je
condamne et je condamne même fermement
ses actions je pense qu'il y a d'autres
moyens de se faire entendre dégrader le
bien public ça n'est pas acceptable
alors sur ces fameux Portices ces cinq
porties qui ont été détruit est-ce que
vous François leco vous dites on
soutient vous soutenez du bout d' lèvres
vous soutenez vraiment vous dites non la
vi comme Bruno le mer finalement la
violence ça résout pas tout quoi c'est
évident que la violence ne résout ne
résout pas tout euh aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que ça arrive un très
mauvais moment euh cette taxe avait
quand enfin cette écotaxe avait quand
même pour comme je l'ai dit au début euh
comme but de de d'éviter de faire venir
des produits loin lointains vous l'avez
dit les autoroutes seront gratuites donc
pour moi ça ne changera rien on va
pénaliser notre commerce de proximité
nos petits producteurs ce que les
politiques veulent développer et et
c'est eux les premiers à être à souffrir
de cette al là on voit les images des
événements qui se sont passés en en
Bretagne du coup vous dites quoi vous
vous cautionnez ou vous vous cautionnez
pas je vais vous dire l'agriculture
d'Île-de-France ne sera pas la poudre
qui enfin l'allumette qui mettra le feu
au poudre sur sur les ivelines donc ça
veut dire que dans les ivelines vous
parliez parce que vous parliez du portic
de woudan vous disiez regardez avec
attention est-ce qu'on pourrait voir ce
genre de chos dans les ivelines vous
allez avoir des mouvements d'humeur
c'est obligatoire aller à la destruction
ça sera certainement pas le but parce
que on sait très bien où cette écotax a
été mal amenée c'est que on a du mal à
comprendre le le prix qu'il a eu pour
récupérer cet impôt ça paraît assez
hallucinant bah le prix de 800 millions
d'euros d'installation de
porti c'est c'est comment récupérer
cette cette taxe après l'entretien de
tous ces porties le personnel qui va
falloir on a l'impression que c'est une
usine à gaz qui ne qui ne pourra pas
aller au bout de sy on va parler du mode
de financement puis je vous demandis
votre avis à tous les deux mais revenir
sur ce je voudrais quand même revenir
sur ce ralbol là il y a des bonis rouges
en Bretagne vous nous dites dans les
iles il y a pas vraiment encore de
ralbol malgré tout ça ça va bouger
ou ça va bouger au niveau agricole on ne
vudrait pas être le déclencheur parce
que les routiers sont très très mal
organisés aujourd'hui parce que la
fédération nationale du transport
routier a passé une négociation avec le
ministère des des transports pour
pouvoir facturer en bas de page le
surcût de l'écotaxe donc pour ces
gens-là ça sera pas compliqué ils sont
beaucoup sur autoroute et ils pourront
comme la TVA remettre l'écotaxe et se la
faire financer beaucoup de petits
transporteurs ne pourront pas comme je
vous dis parce que ils seront en face
d'une grande distribution où ce sont
leurs propres camions et il ne pourront
pas augmenter
dans lesines qui vous disent en gros
voilà combien ça va me coûter est-ce que
pourrait même re en pér on le sait par
cœur euh un un petit camion de 12 tonnes
ça va être 200 € par petit camion pour
aller pour faire 100 km on va dire de
pour aller sur ringis ou des voilà à peu
près le le le le coût que ça va ça va
importer sur la céréal ça va nous coûter
0,50 centimes de la tonne pour pour
aller jusqu'à rouan charger des bateaux
donc euh ça c'est c'est chiffré hein
c'est c'est pas compliqué c'est rien
mais on perd de la compétitivité et
surtout à un moment où les entreprises
ne peuvent pas absorber cette petite
goutte d'eau c'est une petite goutte
d'eau mais qui est supplémentaire à un
très mauvais moment Olivier par vous
l'entendez ça c cette fameuse goutte
d'eau ce ser RAL bol cette taxe qui
arrive en fait au mauvais moment d'après
ce qu'on comprend quand même
effectivement mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est c'est c'est la goutte d'eau qui
fait desbord des le vase mais faut
regarder le vase quand même c'est un
petit peu facile de s'attaquer juste à
la contribution supplémentaire donc
quand on regarde par exemple la Bretagne
la Bretagne c'est quand même un endroit
où on arrive à des aberrations tout le
monde en a parlé des ports qui se vont
en Allemagne pour se faire abattre parce
qu'il y a du dumping social c'est c'est
700000 ports qui se baladent sur les
routes c'est c'est c'est c'est aberrant
et donc cette contribution permet
justement de donner le signe pour ne pas
aller vers ce type d'économie vous
François Le quand il vous dit ça arrive
au mauvais moment ça arrive un moment où
économiquement les agriculteurs étaient
pas prêts à absorber ça et qui nous
donne des des tarifs comme comme 200 €
pour 100 km B 200 € sur 100 km oui mais
50 centimes à la tonne ça fait peut-être
pas énorme ça fait quelques pourcent
donc il a été dit en gros que la les
lescotaxes pénalisé entre 4 et 10 % du
coût du transport qui représente en gros
lui-même 10 % donc on est vraiment dans
des des moins de pour d'augmentation
donc je suis d'accord que ça va ça ça
s'additionne à beaucoup de de contrib
iution qui sont déjà demandé de taxes
d'impôts et cetera mais ce qu'il faut
quand même voir c'est que et en
particulier c'est vrai en Bretagne les
cotaxes ne s'applique encore pas en
Bretagne et si les gens en ont déjà
marre aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a un
problème systémique c'est-à-dire que
entre les abattoirs qui sont délocalisés
entre l'automobile qui va mal et cetera
la Bretagne est très touchée comme
d'autres régions de France et c'est
logique que les gens en a ralbol au bout
d'un moment c'est tout à fait
compréhensible donc ça c'est c'est ce ce
malêtre est tout à fait compré s par
contre s'attaquer à la goutte d'eau qui
fait déborder le vase c'est peut-être
pas la solution par contre je l'ai dit
au début effectivement que le
gouvernement ne sent-êre pas sur ce
sujetl et la suspendre pour la
réappliquer quand même peut-être avec
des adaptations je vous rejoins
exactement sur les autoroutes je vois
pas pourquoi les autoroutes sont
dispensées des cotx ce serait en plus
facile à percevoir au péage donc c'est
quelque chose effectivement dans dans
l'installation de cette fiscalité il y
avait ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur le fait que les camions abîment plus
les routes et que c'est logique qu'on
obtienne une contribution il y avait le
fait que normalement c'était aussi pour
pouvoir taxer les transporteurs ce que
disait monsieur Lecoq c'est exactement
ça transporter les transporteurs
étrangers qui traversent la France sans
payer d'impôt ou sans payer leur côe
part de la rénovation des routes c'est
logique de les de les taxer aussi et
puis ce qu'il faut aussi voir dans les
mesures en quoi cette mesure est
intéressante c'est aussi par exemple la
situation d'Alsace parce qu'on parle de
de la Bretagne mais à l'inverse l'Alsace
pati de l'écotaxe allemande et
l'autoroute à 35 devient un boulevard de
camion allemand qui préfère passer en
France que passer en Allemagne donc en
terme de compétitivité il faut
aussi quand mê l'ession vous retrouve en
tout cas sur un sur un point c'est que
vous àmite vous demandez la suppression
de l'échotax mais vous vous demandez
quand même carrément qu'on revoit cette
écotax quoi c'est pas une application
strit sensus de celle qui est ce qui est
proposé il faut obligatoirement que les
l'état nous mettre des alternatives on
peut mettre une écotaxe en place mais il
faut que derrière on ait une autre
solution si c'est usé moins de gasoel
moi avec mon tracteur ou nos camions
pour faire des petits transports on
pourra pas utiliser le feroutage ou
ouais qu'est-ce qu'on a on a aucune
aucune solution donc de proposer donc
c'est la taxe et puis c'est tout donc
c'est bien c'est je comprends très bien
le message mais le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas c'est pas
applicable sur les entreprises au niveau
de chargge qu'ils ont et et le
consommateur n'est pas ne pourra pas
payer C même pas qu'il a pas envie de
payer c'est qu'il ne pourra pas payer
parce que aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué je voudrais aborder un autre
thème c'est le mode de financement de
cette écotaxe entre le le le type de
contrat signé entre l'État et comove là
aujourd'hui même il y a une commission
parlementaire qui va être mise en place
et notamment l'eurodéputé eva jolie
avait avait demandé qu'il fallait
justement dénoncer ce contrat alors Parà
vous en pensez quoi de ce contrat qui
fait que si l'État français renonce à
cette écotax ça va quand même coûter 800
millions d'euros une grosse somme he
tout à fait tout à fait on est
typiquement dans les effets négatifs des
partenariats public privés qui étaient
très à la mode il y a quelques années et
euh qui éta à la mode qui ont été lancé
par Nicolas Sarkozi qui sont assez
récents malgré tout tout à fait mais sur
lequel on revient de plus en plus le
Conseil régional d'Île-de-France a
décidé de ne plus subventionner de
projets qui soient en partenariat public
privé par exemple donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel je pense que
toutes les collectivités territoriales
ont compris que l'argent pas cher
c'était pas cher à l'instant mais que
dans le temps ça là il s'avère que dans
ce type de contrat il y avait quand même
il y a quand même une somme de 20 % qui
doit être reversé chaque année à ecomove
en fonction de ce que devrait rapporter
lescotaxes c'est estimé à 1,5 milliard
d'euros et il y a 200 millions 250
millions qui doivent revenir àcomou
c'est peut-être ces 20 % qui sont
peut-être un peu excessif en tout cas
c'est sur lequel la commission de
parlementaire va peut-être regarder ça
de près quoi tout à fait tout à fait
mais c'est c'est le principe même des
partenariats public privés où finalement
on va vers l'argent facile et ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher à la la collectivité
et donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument éviter après est-ce qu'il est
possible de se de se dédire de ce que
l'État a c'est déjà engagé auprès des
comov ça je je sais pas le dire ouais
vous avez un avis au niveau de la
Fédération sur cette mode de financement
vous connaissez le le bon sens agricole
et pour un agriculteur un sous est un
sous récolter un impôt en y mettant
autant d'argent pour aller le chercher
pour moi c'est c'est abrant bon ben on
verra ce que dit la commission
parlementaire alors la suite du
mouvement Jean-Marc hraud reçoit demain
les organisations syndicale patronnal et
AG cole sur Al là l'avenir de de la
Bretagne al évidemment lesc cot taxes
sera certainement au centre des débats
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiteriez vous
pour donc pour cette
écotaxe une suppression et ben nous ça
sera c'est la suppression pour
l'agriculture parce que comme je viens
de vous de vous l'indiquer ce n'est pas
supportable pour les entreprises locales
qui font du déplacement avec des petits
camions qui ne peuvent pas faire
autrement que de prendre de d'aller
fournir leurs clients sur Paris la
région parisienne et qui seront sous les
dé portique en permanence parce que on
sait très bien que le consommateur un ne
va ne pourra pas l'avaler et deux on
n'est pas sûr de pouvoir le répercuter
sur la grande distribution d'accord et
ça veut dire avec des mouvements vous
nous l'avez dit peut-être à suivre tout
à fait bon et c'est évident que ces
mouvements risquent d'être suivis par
une partie de la population qui sent
très bien que il y a pas la dynamique le
le gouvernement doit donner une
dynamique sur pour ce pays pour qu'on
puisse sortir de cette crise parce que
il y a des solutions pour sortir mais il
faut mettre envoyer les bons signaux à
la population lundi dernier vous aviez
lundi là vous avez rencontré le le
préfet des yveling qui est venu vous
rencontrer alors c'était pour une visite
qui était déjà programmée hein de longue
date n pas lié à cette à ce sujet mais
je présume qu'il vous a quand même posé
la question il s'est inquiété de savoir
comment allait le moral des agriculteurs
ivinois bah il a vu donc de la de la
grande culture et il a vu aussi des
élevages spécialisés avec un producteur
de pommes et poir sur grandber des gens
qui sont tous les jours à fournir de la
de la grande distribution et qui sont
donc donc avec leur camion sur la route
pour aller livrer qui le cours c'est le
cours qui fait le le le bien-être du
marché de la pomme et aujourd'hui ce
marché il a une très bonne production le
marché est très lourd et ils sont en
concurrence avec des arrivages par
autoroute d'autres endroits de de de
d'Allemagne de pomme qui viennent casser
le marché et le problème il est là c'est
que on est en concurrence déloyale en
permanence parce que les les règles ne
sont pas les mêmes partout en Europe et
c'est ce qu'on demande on est en Europe
il nous faut une règle un unique en
Europe olier para pour pour résumer
votre votre pensée vous demandez à
revoir les cotaxes avec peut-être des
des des allègements ou en tout cas des
améliorations tout à fait non c'est
exactement ça c'est c'est des AM c'est
des aménagements mais par contre la
règle unique aujourd'hui pour l'Europe
c'est plutôt d'aller vers une taxation
des poids lourds c'est une directive
européenne qui est en train de se
décliner dans des pays l'Allemagne le
fait déjà l'Autriche le fait déjà la
République tchèque le fait déjà la la
Suisse enfin qui est pas dans l'Union
européenne mais le fait aussi donc s'il
y a une règle unique ça va plutôt aller
dans le sens d'une contribution euh sur
le sur les transports des poids lourds
donc la la règle unique va plutôt aller
dans ce sens-là donc nous pour les
raisons que j'ai expliqué hein pour les
gaz à effet de serre pour relocaliser
l'agriculture et là-dessus on va se
rejoindre
nécessairement on est pour ce type de de
contribution le le pollueur payeur c'est
donc bien comme ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
aller et et l'État doit donner une
dynamique alors qui est peut-être pas
tout à fait la même dynamique que celle
que vous évoquez mais doit donner une
dynamique qui est aussi de dire que à
terme ce mode de transport ce mode de
développement n'est pas durable pour la
planète et que il faut par une une
fiscalité adapté qui m'attraque pas mais
qui ne m'attraque pas mais mais qui
s'adapte et qui est progressive et qui
donne le signal d'une dynamique sur le
moyen terme c'est vraiment vers ça qu'il
faut aller d'accord merci en tout cas à
vous deux d'avoir participé à ce 78
sociétés alors nous parlions donc ce
soir de l'échotax quatre porties sont
installés dans dans les Ines il en avait
un de plus que nous proposait echomove
Europe Écologie les vers je le rappelle
demande un rétablissement de cette
écotaxe avec des aménagements et puis la
FNSEA syndicat agricole majoritaire en
France par la voie de son secrétaire
général départemental réclame de son
côté sa suppression voilà je vous donne
rendez-vous dans 15 jours pour un
nouveau débat société d'ici là conserver
l'esprit curieux et ouvert surtout à
bientôt